25-year-old left-hander zach lowther
third round draft pick i tell you what
first start of his career not a very
good one that was against the red sox
but his last time out against kansas
city it was good six innings pitch three
hits only one run and that was a solo
home run bow gets a base hit into right
field austin hayes plays it back in
early knockoff single for bogus [ __ ] so
louder gives up a single the bow walks
simeon and guerrero and taos hernandez
will come to the plate
and he hit him
well before the blue jays are retired
they have a run
oscar hernandez gets hit with a
curveball and hit him pretty flush on
the knee i believe
recuperate a little bit here that one
really caught him flush you can see
pointing just to the lower part of his
knee
so that's the tough way to get a ribbing
but the blue jays have the lead a
one-nothing lead still nobody out and
here's lourdes guriel jr he's up to 280
now and he goes after the first pitch
and hits it high into the air in right
field and
grand slam home run for curiel that's
his fourth grand slam of the season how
about lourdes gorilla jr now the
franchise leader for grand slams in a
single season and it's 5-0 toronto and
steven matz goes to the mount to make
the start the 26th start of the season
for stephen this is his third career
start against the orioles last time out
though he was brilliant against the
yankees there's strikes recall the
fastball on the outside corner one down
two out five nothing blue jays
curveball hit on the ground
valera has it
good inning for steven that's three up
three down the oreos go in the quarter
boat leads off for the second straight
inning foul tip strike three
so they went up the ladder the shed a
strikeout victim it's the third one that
louder has picked up simeon stepped into
the plane
and there's another strikeout how about
that four strikeouts in a row now two
down here in the second toronto's
already in front five nothing lefty
louder first pitch to vlady is ripped up
the left field line and that ball is
gone
in no time flat
an absolute rocket for number 44.
i mean you talk about making some noise
vladimir guerrero jr absolutely crushes
that pitch
six nothing toronto louder homeward
flared to shallow center field ureas
going out along with mateo the two
collide urease makes the catch and hangs
on
as the inning comes to a close and
stephen mats has walked the first two
that he has faced
called strike three metz hits that
inside corner and mckenna is called out
on strikes one down sending up the
aforementioned jorge matteo
looper short right field that'll get
down
hang on santander not sure if that was
going to be caught started back to
second so now the bags are loaded and
the orioles will be hitting with the
bases loaded and one out gooniers first
pitch swinging tapper to third the play
to first they get the out there
santander scores and the orioles are on
the board 6-1 toronto in the second
maria slides down to third and mateo
moves up to second they'll take their
chances pitching to the number nine
hitter who comes in with a 173 batting
average
mats delivers a little looper and it is
in for a base hit that'll score two
austin wins got enough bat on it to drop
it
just over the second baseman samian's
head
two rbis for wins and the orioles cut
the lead to six to three there's your
big base hit second and third nobody out
danny janssen popped out his first time
up and here he hits one to left field
left fielder's back it's over mckenna's
head two runs are going to come in to
score bridget's getting waved right
behind guerrilla and danny jensen drives
in a pair with a double
well that's how you answer a team who
scored three runs against you last
inning switch hitter breivik valera
there's a line drive into right field
jansen had to make sure it was down and
he's going to come home and they got a
runner in the run down but janssen will
score valera is tagged out three run
third for toronto nine to three jake
batting ninth today
hits one high into the air deep in right
get up ball get out of here and gone
jake lamb with his first home run as a
blue jay
delivers here in the third and the blue
jays
just can't be stopped
the blue jays get the solo home run for
jake lamb and it's 10-3 toronto bases
loaded up with the walk and then comes
the ninth man of the inning day oscar
hernandez
there's a high five on the right and
this bar's gonna go another home run a
grand slam for tayaska the second grand
slam of the day the eighth of the season
for the blue jays and teo has hit two
grand slams this year
and he will cross the 100 rbi of plateau
as well the blue jays lead 14-3 two down
and blue jays threatening again
carrillo's hit third janson's at second
now bravic valeri there's a high fly
ball to ride this one's carrying deep
get up boy get out of here and off the
fence
valera will drive in two more runs as he
will stop his second with another double
breivik valera has driven in three in
this inning he has driven in three
between the seventh inning last night
and the third inning this afternoon the
blue jays scored 27 runs setting a major
league baseball record for runs scored
over a four inning span stephen matt's
back out he comes home to ryan mount
castle
high fly ball center field it's deep
won't catch this one
ryan montcastle has just tied cal ripken
for the most home runs by an orioles
rookie congratulations ryan you're in
some pretty good company 28 home runs
now 79 rbis and he's putting everybody
on notice that he wants to be the al
rookie of the year
first bring guriel up to the plate
swinging and driving this one's gonna go
again folks way back beyond the walkway
deep in left field for burial his second
home run
of the afternoon that gives him six rbis
in the game and the blue jays have
posted 18. the blue jays have scored
more runs in a single series than they
have in franchise history 43 runs have
been scored in baltimore two outs bases
loaded curiel's had a perfect day two
homers two walks he scored four runs and
driven in
six
takes it down
you'll get another rbi with a walk so
that's
seven rbis for guriel as jake glam comes
in to score brando bridchick has a pair
of hits
gets a base hit to right one run will
score they will just move up 90 feet not
trying to pour it on obviously and they
poured it on base is still loaded two
outs
and danny's gonna get another base hit
and that's gonna score one more run
and they're sending the second rounder
in as well as they oscar and guerrilla
both scoring and danny jansen has a four
rbi day with three hits as steven matz
delivers to anthony santander santander
swings a towering shot to left field
backing up at the wall a look it's in
the stands anthony
leads off the sixth with his 17th long
ball of the year owes cut the lead 22-5
man's trying to clear the sixth swing
and a miss gutierrez down on strike
steven matz completes six innings a five
run ball wins today one for two single
in the second he ground out in the fifth
wins with a drive out to left field this
one looping its way back and just over
the fence austin wins third home run of
the year
and the third lead off long ball for the
orioles today he starts the seventh with
a blast cuts the lead 22-6 dj stewart he
takes a walk the inning continues for
the orioles
that's hit hard in the center field base
hit
stewart around second heading to third
they'll send him in
tyson had a little trouble picking it up
out in center field
and it's an rbi double for austin hayes
there you go action 22 orioles seven two
outs in the ninth inning
ground ball lamb backs up long throw in
time and that's the ball game boy what a
series for the blue jays they take three
or four from baltimore
after losing the opener
and the orioles just didn't have many
answers for the blue jays offense 22-7
here in the series finale
you